chivalry parks and a couple of home runs
in san francisco as you might recall
look at that lineup no bo buchet we just
found out a few minutes ago
scratch from tonight's game with a uh
tightness in his left hamstring so joe
panic moves from third to short brandon
drury
into the lineup at third and they will
face a veteran right-hander in anibal
sanchez
36 eurozone sanchez in his 14th big
league
season he originally signed with the
boston red sox came to the big leagues
with the
miami marlins t oscar hernandez up into
beau bischett's spot
with bichette as we mentioned scratch
just a few minutes ago the nationals one
and two on the season just lost two out
of three at home to the yankees
the oscar hernandez hits it a long way
to right center and it's going to
go just moved up to the lead off spot
about
10 minutes ago and he takes sanchez out
to the opposite field
that ball is gashed out to left center
long run for row blaze
and it'll take a bounce and go into the
bullpen
homer long fly out and a long double for
the first three batters
well there's one thing that can't happen
in the 2020 season
communication problems in the outfield
there's no fans
there's no reason not to communicate and
there's no reason not to know who's got
the ball
victor pulled up right here i don't know
if he thought the fence was coming or he
thought michael a had it
26 year old trent thornton for the first
time he was a rookie last year who went
six and nine
for toronto took pogba out of the lineup
tonight day to day maybe we'll see him
by
tomorrow wednesday or thursday long way
to go for biggio the second baseman
couldn't get a handle castro aboard with
two outs
[Applause]
got under it eaton couldn't find it now
he does
still going back and he can't make the
catch
just never could find it and fisher
comes all the way around a third
let me tell you something i applaud
derek fisher
for getting to third base on that play
that ball is rocked into left
threw his bat and then he threw a rope
into left center
two on one out
high in the air with some carry right
center hernandez going back and that's
off the high part of the wall
thames had to stick around second so he
advances 90 feet
suzuki to second it'll be up to trey
turner to salvage
this bottom of the second 2-2
trey turner under it deep center
hernandez drifting for it
just in front of the track and that adds
passing on an opportunity to at least
tie the game
stranding three bottom of the third adam
eaton struck out looking first time it
was a fastball
he thought was up and away so he's not
waiting around this time
nationals have four hits castro infield
hit
into the love of biggio behind the bag
at second first time
castro got over the top of it and it's
in the left field two on nobody out
and starlin's two for two
lined to left field and the catch is
made by goriel
thornton gets out of trouble again and
at the end of three the blue jays still
lead one to nothing
designated hitter rowdy teles facing
anybody sanchez
as rowdy teles drills one deep right
field we'll get back to that because
rowdy has hit it way out of here
first pitch breaking ball and he looked
like he was sitting on it the blue jays
lead two to nothing
two outs bases empty for the number
eight hitting catcher danny jansen
danny jansen gives one a ride and this
ball's gonna go
it is flying tonight in washington as
jansen has hit the third home run of the
night already for the blue jays
taking a little hand sanitizer over to
rowdy teles
everybody's got to do their part
there's a ball hit hard that's how you
beat the ship
10 seats thames two for
seven as in that sitter and he has a
walk and a knock tonight
suzuki hit it well out to left center
shift on
he rips it fair into the left field
corner and it gets deep into the corner
which helps
thames heading for third chip hale is
going to wave him home
might have a play at the plate and
thames
beats the reload
kern suzuki first rbi of the year
and then ants are on the board that's
what i'm talking about
well that'll work not an easy play
getting the bag was thornton
guerrero had a long way to go thornton
wasn't real quick getting over
and then he couldn't find the bag and
the tongue runs on base
and with turner on the move again a
pop-up joe panic got it
short it's been a long four innings
lots of base runners over 150 pitches
thrown so far
3-1 as the navs get on the board top of
the order to oscar hernandez who was
homered and struck out
would prefer to give rocky a clean
inning as hernandez drills another ball
to deep right field
his second home run of the night his
first two home runs of the year
four solo home runs into toronto four
and washington one
two down for danny jansen who's got one
of the four home runs tonight
now the curveball it's lying to center
solid base hit first hit for the blue
jays
since the second to oscar hernandez home
run back in the fifth inning
janssen at second fischer at first two
down
there's the curve and he got him
right at the knees for strike three
called and the side is retired
turner rocks one into left
turning into a two for four and on base
three straight times
nets need another one of those to get
castro to the plate
as the tying run bass trying to finish
it off right here
weak chopper he's got it throw to first
in time and the blue jays will win it
but what a nice play by anthony bass
eden could run
but the offense they stole the show
tonight they oscar hernandez with two
home runs abuja
scored four runs on seven hits because
they hit four long balls